certaines erreurs font le bonheur des
collections en 1835 quand le
conservateur achète tableau de vélasquez
y croient en réalité acquérir un tableau
de muriaux autre peintre espagnol
également originaire de séville mais un
tout petit peu plus tardif
[Musique]
à cette époque acheter un tableau 2
velasquez aurait tout bonnement était
impossible et n'aurait peut-être pas
intéressé le conservateur alors que
mourinho était un des grands noms de la
peinture recherché par tous les musées
était très chic d'avoir un tableau de
muriaux alors que velasquez était pour
sa part absolument inconnu grâce à cette
erreur le musée des beaux-arts d'orléans
possède aujourd'hui cette oeuvre de
jeunesse unique quasiment unique dans
l'oeuvre du maître qui montre les
premiers pas de ce peintre qui va
représenter à lui seul tout le grand
siècle d'or espagnol ses premiers pas
dans la peinture avec une très forte
influence des peintres de son temps à
commencer par le caravage
[Musique]
ce tableau faisait certainement partie
d'un ensemble de douze apôtres que le
peintre souhaitait réaliser
finalement seuls deux ont été peints
celui de barcelone et celui du musée des
beaux-arts d'orléans
[Musique]